It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是盛花期，我的业务正飞速扩张。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这绝对是个不会常有的优惠。今天就来探索 Google Fi Wireless 的套餐吧。另需税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. No one gets through life unscathed. We all encounter difficult and painful things. We get sick, our loved ones die, we live through natural disasters and wars. Many people would call these events traumatic, and they do have the potential to traumatize us. But in recent years, psychologists have found something surprising. Most people managed to get through terrible times and come out the other side without lasting trauma. Today we're going to talk to a researcher who studies the psychology of
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。没有人能毫发无损地走过一生。我们都会遇到困难和痛苦的事情。我们会生病，我们爱的人会离去，我们经历自然灾害和战争。许多人会称这些事件为创伤，它们确实有可能让我们受到创伤。但近年来，心理学家发现了一个令人惊訝的事情。大多数人都能度过艰难时期，并安然无恙地走出阴影，而不会留下持久的创伤。今天我们要采访一位研究以下领域的学者：
human loss, grief, and resilience about why we may be more resilient than we realize. So what is trauma? What is resilience? Why do people sometimes develop post-traumatic stress disorder or lasting trauma after a terrible experience while other times they don't? And what can we learn from this research that can help us handle difficult times and treat or even prevent lasting trauma? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. George Bonanno, a professor of psychology at Teachers College, Columbia
人类的失落、悲伤与韧性的心理学，探讨为什么我们可能比自己意识到的更有韧性。那么，什么是创伤？什么是韧性？为什么人们有时在经历可怕的经历后会患上创伤后应激障碍或留下持久的创伤，而有时却不会？我们能从这项研究中学到什么，来帮助我们应对困难时期，治疗甚至预防持久的创伤？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是哥伦比亚大学教师学院的心理学教授乔治·博纳诺博士，
University, where he leads the loss, trauma, and emotion lab. His research centers on the question of how humans cope with loss, potential trauma, and extreme life events, and the factors that lead to resilience in the face of adversity. He's the author of hundreds of peer-reviewed scientific articles and three books including his most recent, The End of Trauma, How the New Science of Resilience is Changing, How We Think About PTSD. Dr. Bonano, thank you for joining me today. Thank you, Kim. Nice to be here with you.
他在那里领导失落、创伤和情感实验室。他的研究核心是人类如何应对失落、潜在创伤和极端生活事件，以及在逆境中产生韧性的因素。他是数百篇同行评审科学论文和三本著作的作者，其中包括他的最新著作《创伤的终结：韧性的新科学如何改变我们对创伤后应激障碍的看法》。博纳诺博士，谢谢你今天能来。谢谢你，金。很高兴能和你在一起。
Let's start with the basics. How does psychology define resilience? What does that term mean? Well, people define it somewhat different. ways, but in my research and in a lot of, I think a lot of people have adopted this approach, I define resilience exclusively as an outcome. So I think you have to be resilient to something. And I define resilience as in the simplest terms of stable trajectory of healthy functioning after exposure to some extreme anniversary or potential trauma. And I do that computationally,
让我们从基础开始。心理学是如何定义韧性的？这个词是什么意思？嗯，人们对它的定义略有不同，但在我的研究中，以及在许多——我想很多人都采纳了这种方法——我将韧性纯粹定义为一种结果。所以我认为你必须对某事具有韧性。我将韧性简单定义为在经历某种极端逆境或潜在创伤后，保持健康功能的稳定轨迹。我是用计算方法来做这件事的，
but, you know, it's basically a stable trajectory of just good health afterwards. Is resilience baked into us? In other words, is there a biological or genetic component to it? I think that the capacity to be resilient is part of human nature. It's part of who we are. It's a result of millions of years of evolution. We have a tremendous capacity to adapt, It's probably more than most creatures on Earth, maybe more than all creatures on Earth, because there are a number of things that characterize human development and the way the brain works that are pretty unique. And it allows us to modify and adjust to all kinds of things.
但是，你知道，这基本上就是事后保持身体健康的稳定轨迹。韧性是天生赋予我们的吗？换句话说，它有生物学或遗传成分吗？我认为具备韧性的能力是人性的一部分。它是我们的一部分。它是数百万年演化的结果。我们拥有巨大的适应能力，可能比地球上的大多数生物都要多，也许比地球上的所有生物都要多，因为人类发展和大脑工作的方式有许多相当独特的特征。它使我们能够修改和调整以适应各种事情。
We're very flexible creatures. What is it that makes some people more resilient than others? Resilience to an aversive event doesn't just happen. I don't think resilience is a characteristic of people or a trait. Resilience is an effortful outcome that happens when people adapt themselves to the challenges of the situation they've been presented with. And that requires what I call now regulatory flexibility. You could also call this behavioral flexibility. It's this capacity or this ability to adapt to the challenge of the moment.
我们是非常灵活的生物。究竟是什么让人比其他人更有韧性？对逆境事件的韧性不是凭空产生的。我不认为韧性是人的某种特征或特质。韧性是一种努力的结果，当人们调整自己以适应所面临的情境挑战时，这种结果就会发生。这就需要我现在所说的调节灵活性。你也可以称之为行为灵活性。这就是适应当前挑战的容量或能力。
And of course, as the scientists, we've broken this down into its constituent parts, but we find when we study those parts, those pieces of this basic flexibility, that people do vary in those abilities. In your latest book, you write that although terrible things have always happened to people, the idea of trauma is a more modern concept. When and how did trauma as a concept develop? And what did people think happen to them before that? That's a great question. It's very curious. I think that psychological trauma was probably around for a very long time, but it wasn't anything that we really have any record of curiously. If we go back in time to the earliest forms of literature that we have, you know, oral traditions that were put in the stories. A great example is Homer's, Iliad and Odyssey, right? And the Iliad is just filled with war and battle. And there is grief in the Iliad. The soldiers in the Iliad openly grieve. They grieve in front of their enemy.
当然，作为科学家，我们已经把它分解成了各个组成部分，但我们发现在研究这些部分、这种基本灵活性的碎片时，人们在这些能力上确实有所不同。在你的最新书中，你写道，尽管人们一直都在经历可怕的事情，但创伤的概念是一个更现代的概念。作为概念的创伤是在什么时候以及如何发展起来的？在此之前，人们认为发生了什么？这是一个很好的问题。这非常奇怪。我认为心理创伤可能已经存在了很长时间，但奇怪的是，我们没有任何真正的记录。如果我们回溯到我们拥有的最早形式的文学作品，你知道，那些被编成故事的口头传统。一个很好的例子就是荷马的《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》，对吧？《伊利亚特》里充满了战争和战斗。《伊利亚特》中有悲伤。书中的士兵公开悲伤。他们在敌人面前悲伤。
They talk about it. But there's no evidence of anything remotely like PTSD. And you don't see this really anywhere in our history until really, well, it really was first acknowledged explicitly in the 19th century psychological trauma. The first written record is probably in the 17th century in the diaries of a guy named Samuel Pepys. And Peeps is, you know, there's some of you out there will know Peeps or Peepsophiles in the world. I have a big fan of Samuel Peep's. I've read all of his diaries. So what Peeps was is an aristocrat who kept a diary for about 10 years, wrote down everything unabashedly.
他们谈论它。但没有任何证据表明有任何类似于创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的东西。在我们的历史中，你真的看不到这一点，直到——嗯，它直到19世纪才被明确承认为心理创伤。最早的文字记录可能是在17世纪一个叫塞缪尔·皮普斯的日记里。皮普斯这个人，在座的有些人会知道皮普斯，或者是世上的“皮普斯迷”。我是塞缪尔·皮普斯的超级粉丝。我读过他所有的日记。所以皮普斯是一个贵族，他写了大约10年的日记，无所畏忌地记录了一切。
He wrote about his hemorrhoids. He wrote about, you know, all kinds of other things. And he didn't really, arguably, didn't really intend it to be read during his lifetime. He wrote in a kind of a quasi code. And then when he died, he donated his entire library, quite a library. He donated it to the University of Cambridge. I think, well, Cambridge had it. I don't know if he gave it to them, but they had it.
他写了他的痔疮。他写了，你知道，各种各样其他的事情。而且他真的，可以说，并没有打算在他有生之年被人阅读。他用一种准密码来写。然后他死后，他把他整个图书馆捐了出去，相当大的一个图书馆。他把它捐给了剑桥大学。我想，嗯，剑桥拥有它。我不知道他是不是送给他们的，但他们确实拥有了。
They had it for about 100 years before they actually got around to figuring it out. And then when they did, they realized that there was a treasure trove of information. It's like being in somebody's head in the 17th century, 1666, for example. So in 1666, he had been living in London during the Great London Fire, when more than half of the city burned. And he was asked by the king to survey the damage. So he went around and went to places where the fire was still going. He talked about the bottoms of his feet feeling they were on fire,
他们拥有它大约100年，然后才真正开始弄清楚它。然后当他们这样做时，他们意识到那里有一个信息宝库。就像进入17世纪某人的脑海里一样，例如1666年。所以在1666年，他一直在伦敦经历伦敦大火，当时大火烧毁了一半以上的城市。国王请他去调查损失情况。所以他四处走动，去了火势仍在蔓延的地方。他谈到自己的脚底感觉像着了火一样，
seeing horrible carnage. And he, in his diary, he suffered, he suffered greatly and he had nightmares, and he wrote about this in his diary. And he was very confused about it in his diary. He said things like, you know, I don't understand why I'm unable to sleep for these horrible images of fire that keep invading my brain. This may be six months later. So that speaks volumes, I think, because it suggested he was having trauma symptoms, as we know of them today, symptoms of PTSD, I should say, and he didn't know what to make of it. And he didn't tell anybody, as far as we know,
看到了可怕的惨状。他在日记里，他遭受了，他遭受了巨大的痛苦，并且做了噩梦，他在日记里写了这些。他在日记里对此感到非常困惑。他说了一些这样的话，你知道，我不明白为什么我无法入睡，因为这些不断侵入我大脑的火灾的可怕画面。这可能是六个月后。所以我认为这说明了很多问题，因为它表明他当时有着我们今天所知的创伤症状，或者说创伤后应激障碍的症状，而且他不知道该如何面对。据我们所知，他没有告诉任何人，
he put it in his diary. And this is the first written account we have of anything like that. And so it appears that traumatic events, certainly know people were subject to all kinds of horrific things in the past. We were often prey for all kinds of, you know, with little defenses. But we didn't seem to know what to think of those responses. And it raises
他把它写在了日记里。这是我们拥有的关于此类事件的第一份书面记录。因此，这表明创伤事件——当然，我们知道过去的人们曾遭受过各种各样可怕的事情。我们常常是各种事物的猎物，你知道的，防范措施很少。但我们似乎不知道该如何看待这些反应。这就引出了
questions, maybe they weren't as prevalent in the past as they were now. We just don't know the answers to those questions. One of the main findings of your work is that we're more resilient than we realize that not every potentially traumatic event causes lasting trauma. What's the difference between trauma at a potentially traumatic event? So I started using the word potential trauma or a potentially traumatic event. I don't know, about 10 or 15 years ago now, and I had to force myself to concentrate
问题：也许它们在过去的发生率并不像现在这么高。我们只是不知道这些问题的答案。你工作的主要发现之一是，我们比自己意识到的更有韧性，并非每个潜在的创伤事件都会导致持久的创伤。创伤与潜在创伤事件之间有什么区别？所以我开始使用“潜在创伤”或“潜在创伤事件”这个词。我不知道，大约是10或15年前，我不得不强迫自己集中注意力
and to do that because we have a tendency to call things traumas, anything violent or life-threatening. We then think of the trauma. But this gets us into all kinds of conceptual trouble because we then assume that anytime any person, but he's been through a violent or life-sreatening event, like automobile accident, a natural disaster,
并这样做，因为我们有一种倾向，把任何暴力或威胁生命的事件都叫做创伤。然后我们就会想到创伤。但这让我们陷入了各种概念上的麻烦，因为我们随后会假设，任何经历过暴力或威胁生命的事件（如车祸、自然灾害、
a terrorist attack, a disease pandemic, a civil war, an assault, anything like that, that they will be then traumatized because they've been through a trauma. The facts are that people that go through these somewhat horrific category of events, they are mostly not traumatized. In other words, they mostly do not suffer lasting damage. So calling them traumas is just confusing to people. So as I said, I forced myself to call these events potentially traumatic events. And this is really from an eye of trying to understand
恐怖袭击、疾病大流行、内战、袭击之类的事情）的人，都会因为他们经历过创伤而受到创伤。事实是，经历过这些有点可怕的事件的人，大多数都没有受到创伤。换句话说，他们大多数没有遭受持久的损害。所以把它们叫做创伤只会让人感到困惑。所以正如我所说，我强迫自己把这些事件称为“潜在创伤事件”。这确实源于试图理解
what these events are and what they do to us. And so it's a lot easier or a lot more conceptually clear to say these are potentially traumatic events. Now what happens when somebody is exposed to want and we can then track that. Are there differences of sensitivity that make the difference for people so somebody is traumatized? Somebody goes to war and comes back and doesn't really think about it again and other people can ruminate on it for the rest of their lives, for example. Yeah. There are a lot of different factors that have been identified.
这些事件是什么以及它们对我们做了什么。因此，说这些是潜在创伤事件要简单得多，概念上也更清晰。现在，当某人暴露在其中一个事件中时会发生什么，我们可以对此进行追踪。人们对敏感性的差异是否会造成区别，从而导致某人受到创伤？例如，一个人去参军，回来后就不怎么去想它了，而另一个人则会在余生中对此反复咀嚼。是的。人们已经确定了许多不同的因素。
There are some epigenetic effects. In other words, people, this is typically people who have been to pretty dramatic things when they were younger and their stress response, their HPA axis, the main neuro hormonal system in the body that produces cortisol, which helps us defend against these aversive events, that those systems are either overly active, which tends to lead to depression, or they're underactive, which tends to actually lead to PTSD. But these differences have been identified. So when people go through horrific events for a prolonged period of horrific events in the past, their system can be epigenetically, that is, the way genes are expressed, gets altered so that they either react too much or not
有一些表观遗传效应。换句话说，这些人通常是那些在年轻时经历过相当戏剧性事情的人，他们的压力反应，即下丘脑-垂体-肾上腺（HPA）轴——体内产生皮质醇的主要神经内分泌系统，皮质醇帮助我们抵御这些逆境事件——这些系统要么过度活跃，往往会导致抑郁，要么活跃不足，实际上往往会导致创伤后应激障碍。但这些差异已经被识别出来了。因此，当人们在过去经历长时间的可怕事件时，他们的系统可能会在表观遗传上发生改变，也就是说基因表达的方式被改变了，导致他们的反应要么过强，要么不足
enough. And these effects have been identified. The problem is, in a statistical sense, their small effects. And what that means in just plain languages, they don't really explain very much. Similarly, we did a study where we had tracked different patterns of outcome after potential traumas, and we looked at what are called polygenic scores, and this is the entire genome that's weighted against certain outcomes.
不够。这些效应已经被确认了。问题在于，从统计学意义上讲，它们的效应很小。用大白话来说，这意味着它们其实并不能解释太多东西。同样，我们做过一项研究，追踪了潜在创伤后不同的结果模式，我们研究了所谓的“多基因评分”，这是针对某些结果加权的全基因组。
And we used the known polygenic scores, and we found there were some of these scores that did predict who would be resilient and who not, certain patterns of scores, of certain patterns, I'm sorry, of genes, but again, the effects are small. And this is true of just about everything that we know of that either predicts PTSD or recovery or resilience, these different patterns we might show. The effects of any individual factor don't explain very much. And this has been a puzzle for me personally, this has been a puzzle I've been trying to solve for years.
我们使用了已知的多基因评分，发现其中一些评分确实能预测谁会具有韧性，谁不会，某些基因评分模式，某些模式，抱歉，是基因模式，但再次强调，这些效应很小。这几乎适用于我们所知道的、用于预测创伤后应激障碍、恢复或韧性的所有因素，即我们可能表现出的这些不同模式。任何单个因素的效应都无法解释太多。这对我个人来说一直是个谜，这是一个我多年来一直试图解开的谜。
And this is where I got onto the idea of what I'm calling flexibility. The capacity to adapt is when we utilize the tools that we have to adjust to an outcome. It's our capacity to use whatever tools we have to adapt to the challenge. And individual differences or differences in that ability carry a lot of weight in predicting
正是在这里，我接触到了我所称的“灵活性”的概念。适应能力是指我们利用拥有的工具来调整以适应某种结果。这是我们利用我们拥有的任何工具来适应挑战的能力。这种能力的个体差异或差异在预测
who will be traumatized, who will be resilient, et cetera. You described four trajectories that people can follow after they experience a loss or a tragedy. Where are they? How common are they? The trajectories we've identified in our research, and I should point out that we've identified these trajectories now many, many times in recent review papers and one my team conducted, one other recent paper and the other team conducted, there have been over 100 studies that have shown these same patterns. That's one of the most replicable things in psychology. And what we find with those, there are other patterns, but the four patterns we see mostly,
谁会受到创伤、谁会具有韧性等方面具有很大的分量。你描述了人们在经历失落或悲剧后可以遵循的四种轨迹。它们是什么？它们有多普遍？我们在研究中确定了这些轨迹，我应该指出，我们在最近的综述论文以及我的团队、另一个最近的论文和其他团队进行的论文中，已经多次确定了这些轨迹，已有100多项研究显示了这些相同的模式。这是心理学中最具可复现性的事情之一。我们发现，除了其他模式之外，我们看到最多、
predominantly are one chronic symptoms. That's a lot like having chronic PTSD. It's high levels of symptoms and distress that last for at least a year or two after exposure to a potentially traumatic event. So you could consider that chronically not doing well, chronically elevated symptoms. That pattern occurs anywhere from about 5 to 30%. The maximum is around 30%, which is an awful lot. When I first began to do this, people took issue with the fact that I was saying it was 30% was the ceiling the most
最主要的四种模式是：第一种是慢性症状。这很像患有慢性创伤后应激障碍。它是在暴露于潜在创伤事件后，持续至少一到两年的高水平症状和痛苦。所以你可以认为这是慢性状态下表现不佳、症状持续升高。这种模式的发生率大约在5%到30%之间。最高约为30%，这相当惊人。当我刚开始做这个研究时，人们对我说30%是大多数情况下的上限这一说法提出异议，
because it was thought that more people in that would have PTSD. And in fact, that's about the most we've ever seen. But 30% is a lot of people, right? It's a lot of people. Usually it's 5 to 10% somewhere in that range. They will develop a chronic PTSD or other type of reaction. And for some pretty horrific events, it could be higher. So that's one pattern, chronically elevated symptoms.
因为人们曾认为会有更多的人患上创伤后应激障碍。事实上，这大约是我们见过最高的数据了。但30%也是很多人了，对吧？这是一个很大的数字。通常这个比例在5%到10%左右。他们会发展出慢性的创伤后应激障碍或其他类型的反应。对于一些相当可怕的事件，比例可能会更高。所以这是一种模式，即症状持续升高的慢性模式。
Another one we see, which is very interesting, we call recovery. It's when people have a big burst in symptoms. They're an acute reaction. They're not doing well. And they don't recover right away. It takes maybe a year or two to recover. So it's kind of a gradual alleviation of symptoms. But people showing that pattern do eventually sort of get back to where they were before,
我们看到的另一种非常有趣的模式，我们称之为“恢复”。这是指人们的症状突然爆发。他们有急性反应。他们情况不佳。而且他们没有立刻恢复。可能需要一到两年的时间才能恢复。所以这是一种症状逐渐缓解的过程。但表现出这种模式的人最终确实会回到他们之前的状态，
back to baseline in a sense. And we see that pattern, you know, somewhere between five and say 20, 25%. It's not, you know, and it varies. These are on average. These are the estimates. Then we see a third pattern with when we're talking about potential traumatic events. We call worsening. we could call it delayed symptom elevations.
某种意义上回到了基线。我们看到这种模式的比例在大约5%到20%、25%之间。它并非，你知道的，而且它会有所变化。这些都是平均值。这些是估计值。然后我们看到第三种模式，当我们谈论潜在创伤事件时。我们称之为“恶化”。我们也可以称之为“延迟的症状升高”。
But what's kind of interesting about that pattern, back in the days when people didn't think resilience was real, and there was definitely a time when I first began reporting resilience, people thought it was just an artifact of some statistical trick I was doing. I took a lot of grief in those days for publishing papers saying, no, look, most people are resilient. So the belief was that resilience was really kind of a denial and that people who were showing this healthy pattern were really not doing well at all, but they were kind of suppressing it or hiding it. And then eventually out of the blue, they would have a major trauma reaction because it would come to roost eventually.
但这种模式有趣的地方在于，在过去人们不认为韧性是真实存在的时代——当时我刚开始报告韧性时，确实有一段时期，人们认为这只是我所做的某种统计把戏的人为产物。我在那些日子里因为发表论文说“不，看，大多数人都是有韧性的”而饱受非议。因此当时的信念是，韧性实际上只是一种否认，表现出这种健康模式的人其实根本状态很糟，但他们某种程度上在压抑或隐藏它。然后最终，由于这种情绪最终会积压爆发，他们会莫名其妙地产生强烈的创伤反应。
And there's really no, not a real clear biological, neurological reason why that would be the case, but that was the belief. And when we began to tracking people over time and mapping these trajections, we never saw that pattern. But what we do see instead is this worsening pattern where people, and this is other investigators have reported this as well, where people are struggling, but they're, what we'd say, below threshold. They don't really meet the criteria to have PTSD, say, or another disorder, but they're not perfectly healthy either. They're kind of struggling. And then they're gradually getting worse. and that gradually getting worse, at some point, they crossed a line into the enough of a symptom
而且这确实没有真正清晰的生物学、神经学原因来解释为什么会这样，但这就是当时的信念。当我们开始随着时间追踪人们并绘制这些轨迹时，我们从未看到那种模式。但相反，我们看到的是这种恶化模式，即人们正在挣扎，但他们处于我们所说的“阈值以下”。他们实际上不符合创伤后应激障碍等疾病的标准，但他们也并非完全健康。他们有点在挣扎。然后他们逐渐恶化。这种逐渐恶化的过程在某个时间点跨越了一条线，达到了足够的症状
profile to meet diagnostic criteria. So now they have PTSD, but it's not like it just came out of the blue. They were just gradually getting worse and then crossed that somewhat arbitrary line into where we would consider it PTSD. We do see that pattern. And we see that pattern. We sometimes don't see that pattern. But when we do it, it's usually around, I don't know, 15, 20 percent. All of these are in that kind of domain. But the largest pattern that we see, the most common is the pattern we call resilience, the resilience trajectory. And that are people who have been through a potential trauma. They may have a little bit of a bump in, you know, they may struggle for a week or two, maybe a little bit longer because tension traumatic events are really lousy events, you know,
特征以满足诊断标准。所以现在他们患上了创伤后应激障碍，但这并不是说它凭空出现。他们只是逐渐恶化，然后跨越了我们认为是创伤后应激障碍的那条有些随意的线。我们确实看到了这种模式。有时我们看不到这种模式。但当我们看到它时，比例通常在15%到20%左右。所有这些都在这个范围内。但我们看到的最大、最常见的模式是我们称之为“韧性”的模式，即“韧性轨迹”。这就是那些经历过潜在创伤的人。他们的情绪可能会有一点小波折，你知道的，他们可能会挣扎一两周，也许会稍微久一点，因为潜在创伤事件确实是很糟糕的事件，你知道的，
and they're really disturbing. They give people nightmares sometimes. They have intrusive thoughts. that's all very normal in the beginning right in the first week or two. It's not uncommon. And so they may have those reactions, but then they're basically regained whatever equilibrium they had, and they continue to function in what I had mentioned before, a stable trajectory of healthy functioning. Now, when I began my career, I started doing this in 1991. It was assumed that hardly anybody showed that pattern.
它们真的很令人不安。它们有时会让人做噩梦。他们会有侵入性想法。这在刚开始的一两周内都是非常正常的。这并不罕见。因此他们可能会有这些反应，但随后他们基本上恢复了他们所拥有的任何平衡，并继续以我之前提到的一种健康功能的稳定轨迹运转。现在，当我开始我的职业生涯时，我是在1991年开始做这门研究的。当时人们认为几乎没有人表现出这种模式。
It was assumed that people that had little or no symptoms were very rare. And if they did show that pattern, that there was probably something wrong with those people. They were in denial. It was a kind of a weird pathological personality that would not react to these events. But when we began to track people over time, we found, in fact, this is where most people were. Most people were showing that pattern. That is the norm. And we've shown this now over and over and over in so many studies, that is the normative pattern.
当时人们认为几乎没有或根本没有症状的人非常罕见。如果他们确实表现出这种模式，那么这些人可能有什么不对劲。他们在否认。这是一种对这些事件没有反应的奇怪的病态人格。但当我们开始随着时间追踪人们时，我们发现，事实上，这才是大多数人的状态。大多数人都表现出这种模式。这才是常态。我们现在已经在无数的研究中一次又一次地证明了这一点，这才是规范的模式。
We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll talk more with Dr. Bonano about treatments for trauma and how people can build their capacity for resilience. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed
我们要休息一会儿，回来后我们将继续与博纳诺博士讨论创伤的治疗以及人们如何建立韧性能力。家得宝阵亡将士纪念日大促，你的夏天从现在开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四火眼燃气烤炉开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅售 199 美元。还可以用售价仅 499 美元的 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅，整个季节尽情招待亲友。今年阵亡将士纪念日，尽在家得宝享受
at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply, see Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
全场低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期限为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用除外条款，详情请参见 Homedepot.com/pricematch。你曾说过这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。
Enough to get lost. Or you could book a lot. stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. So what are the implications of your work for treatment and helping people who are suffering from PTSD or traumatic event? Okay, that's a great question. And I'm moving in that direction now. You know, I'm a trained clinical psychologist. I'm a professor in a clinical psychology program, an APA accredited clinical
够去浪迹天涯了。或者你可以预订 Hilton 住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。Hilton 特卖现正进行中。在 Hilton.com 或 Hilton App 上预订，最高可省 20%，享受您期望的住宿。当您想要节省而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。Hilton 助您乐享住宿。那么，您的研究对治疗和帮助遭受创伤后应激障碍或创伤事件折磨的人有什么启示呢？好的，这是一个很好的问题。我目前正朝着这个方向前进。你知道，我是一名训练有素的临床心理学家。我是临床心理学项目的教授，一个经 APA 认证的临床
psychology program, but I haven't done any kind of intervention work in probably about 30 years now. I've just devoted myself to doing research. However, for the first time, I'm developing a training for this concept I mentioned flexibility, because we have enough evidence now to conclude that this is how people find resilience through enacting these flexibility components. And I'm fairly confident that we would also be able to help people who are suffering more
心理学项目，但我已经有大约 30 年没有做过任何干预工作了。我只是全身心地投入到研究中。然而，我第一次正在为我提到的“灵活性”这个概念开发培训，因为我们现在有足够的证据得出结论：人们正是通过实施这些灵活性组件来找到韧性的。而且我相当确信，我们也能够帮助那些挣扎得更厉害的人，
with either having a difficult time recovering or showing a chronic pattern of elevated symptoms or PTSD. see, I think people would benefit from learning or practicing these skills as well. I think the skills are already part of our human makeup, but most things need are a combination of kind of some innate tendency and learning. And it takes a while to learn how to regulate yourself, how to adjust yourself in the world. This is one of the things we do through our long 25 years or so when our brains are are developing, our cortex is developing. So I think teaching these skills, and the fairly clear set of
无论是恢复困难，还是表现出症状持续升高的慢性模式，或是创伤后应激障碍。你看，我认为人们也会受益于学习或练习这些技能。我认为这些技能已经是我们人类构成的一部分，但大多数事情都需要某种先天倾向和学习的结合。学会如何自我调节、如何在这个世界上调整自己需要一段时间。这是我们在大脑发育、皮层发育的长达 25 年左右的时间里所做的事情之一。所以我认为教授这些技能，一套相当清晰的
skills, is something that can really help people. So in practical terms, what does that look like? I mean, I'm thinking of like exposure therapy. Is that one of the types of things that you would be recommending? I think exposure therapy has got a really great track record. Exposure therapy does work for PTSD. Yeah. It probably works better than just about anything that's been tried, although there are other approaches that work pretty well, too, that are not nearly. Reexposure therapy is a challenging type of treatment to both to do and to receive. It's intense, but it's, you know, the intensity pays off based, this is what the evidence tells us. But there are other approaches that have to do with systematic relaxation,
技能，是真正能帮助人们的事情。那么在实际操作中，这看起来是怎样的？我的意思是，我想到了暴露疗法。那是你会推荐的类型之一吗？我认为暴露疗法有着非常好的记录。暴露疗法对创伤后应激障碍确实有效。是的。它可能比尝试过的几乎任何其他方法都更有效，尽管还有其他效果也相当不错的途径，虽然不完全一样。重新暴露疗法是一种具有挑战性的治疗类型，无论是实施还是接受。它很紧张，但是，你知道，这种强度是有回报的，证据就是这样告诉我们的。但还有其他方法，与系统性放松有关，
and finding ways to calm oneself, right? And there are other interventions having to do with, that are more behavioral or more cognitive, thinking about how to manage the symptoms. And earlier in my career, I worked with a lot of PTSD patients, and we tried a various mix of these things. The flexibility approach, we call this regulatory flexibility, or specifically the flexibility sequence,
并找到自我平静的方法，对吧？还有其他干预措施，更多是行为方面的或认知方面的，思考如何管理症状。在我职业生涯的早期，我曾与许多创伤后应激障碍患者合作，我们尝试了这些事情的各种组合。灵活性方法，我们称之为调节灵活性，或者具体称为灵活性序列，
this has three main parts. The first part we call context sensitivity, which is about reading the situational cues, reading the context, the challenge we're facing in the moment, and deciding what the problem is, what that problem is in the moment, and then deciding to do something about it, to form a goal to deal with that problem.
这有三个主要部分。第一部分我们称为情境敏感性，它是关于阅读情境线索，阅读情境，我们当下所面临的挑战，并决定问题是什么，当下那个问题是什么，然后决定为此做些什么，形成一个应对该问题的目标。
Then the next step, So, for example, before I go to the next step, I might be feeling very anxious. And for, say, I'm feeling anxious and something bad is going to happen, I might do that for a day or two. But at some point, I can realize the problem I'm struggling with right now is that I'm feeling anxious. So what can I do about that? If we've been through a broader situation like a natural disaster and automobile accident and potentially traumatic event, we have a tendency to think of ourselves as traumatized and think in this much broader way, this larger scale way of I'm traumatized, which is a very difficult thing to conceptualize and to
然后下一步，所以，例如，在我进入下一步之前，我可能会感到非常焦虑。并且，比如说，我感到焦虑，将会有坏事发生，我可能会这样持续一两周。但在某个时刻，我会意识到我当前正在挣扎的问题是我感到焦虑。那么我能对此做些什么呢？如果我们经历过更广泛的情况，比如自然灾害、车祸和潜在创伤事件，我们往往会认为自己受到了创伤，并以这种更广阔的方式、更大规模的方式去思考，认为我受到了创伤，这是一种非常难以概念化和
move beyond. But if we think more locally, what's the problem I'm facing right now? And that problem might be that I'm feeling anxious, that I'm having trouble sleeping, that I'm having a difficult time concentrating, we have to narrow our approach down to a problem that we can actually manage and that is actually impinging on us at the moment. And that's what this first step is, this context part, context sensitivity, we're reading the cues. What is it that my body's telling me? What is it that my experiences in my life right now this day are telling me about what the problem is? So we focus, we get in a sense are picking out a problem to address. Then we move to the next step, which is we actually do something to solve that problem.
超越的事情。但如果我们想得更本地化一点，我目前面临的问题是什么？那个问题可能是，我感到焦虑，我失眠，我很难集中精力，我们必须将我们的方法缩小到一个我们实际上可以管理的、并且目前正在侵扰我们的问题上。这就是第一步，情境部分，情境敏感性，我们在解读线索。我的身体在告诉我什么？我今天的生活经历在告诉我关于问题是什么的什么信息？所以我们聚焦，在某种程度上挑选出一个要解决的问题。然后我们进入下一步，也就是我们实际采取行动来解决那个问题。
We call that step the repertoire step because it hinges on the tools that we have, our repertoire of strategies, tools we have in our toolbox. So we're evaluating the situation, we're asking ourselves, what's happening to me? What do I need to do? And then in the repertoire step, we're asking ourselves, what am I able to do? What do I have at my disposal? And teaching people about this is almost a matter of psychoeducation because we have to, many times we don't even know what the strategies we really have are.
我们把这一步称为“贮备步”，因为它取决于我们拥有的工具、我们的策略贮备、我们工具箱里的工具。因此，我们在评估情况，我们在问自己，我身上发生了什么？我需要做什么？然后在贮备步中，我们问自己，我能做什么？我手头有什么？向人们传授这一点几乎就像是一种心理教育，因为很多时候我们甚至不知道我们真正拥有什么策略。
It's a good thing to develop a sense of that. When we're in the midst of a difficult time, it's a little harder to think clearly in this way. So we go through the first two steps. We are assessing the challenge we're facing right in this moment. We decide what we're going to focus on. We go to our repertoire of strategies and we pick something. and we often do this without really even thinking about it. It's a sort of natural ability.
培养这种意识是一件好事。当我们处于艰难时期时，要这样清晰地思考会更困难一点。所以我们经历前两步。我们正在评估我们此刻面临的挑战。我们决定我们要关注什么。我们去寻找我们的策略贮备并挑选一个。我们常常甚至在不假思索的情况下就这么做了。这是一种自然的能力。
And then the third step is very important. We call it the feedback step. What all it really is comprised of is monitoring what we just did, the strategy we just used to see if it worked. And this is where a lot of people, I know clinically a lot of people struggle because we're struggling with something. We try some way to get beyond it. It doesn't work.
然后第三步非常重要。我们称之为“反馈步”。它实际上只包含了一点：监测我们刚刚做过的事、我们刚刚使用的策略，看它是否管用。这就是许多人——我知道在临床上很多人都在挣扎的地方，因为我们在挣扎。我们尝试某种方法来走出来。它不管用。
And we assume we can't do it. I give up. I'm not good at this. I'm feeling anxious. I tried a breathing exercise. It didn't help. I don't know what to do. I can't deal with this.
我们就认为我们做不到。我放弃了。我不擅长这个。我感到焦虑。我尝试了呼吸练习。它没有帮助。我不知道该怎么办。我应付不了这个。
I'm anxious. But in fact, human beings like most all animals cope by trial and error. Nobody gets it right the first time. Even the healthiest people don't get it right the first time. It's a matter of, it's almost like a machine learning algorithm or an AI algorithm. Take a crack at it, see what happens. And then you find out, did that work? No, okay, what else do I have to try?
我很焦虑。但事实上，人类就像大多数动物一样，是通过试错来应对的。没有人第一次就能做对。即使是最健康的人第一次也做不对。这就像是一种机器学习算法或人工智能算法。尝试一下，看看会发生什么。然后你就会发现，那个管用吗？没有，好吧，我还有什么可以尝试的？
And this is very much what the research tells us, that people cope by trial and error. Sometimes it takes four or five tries. But when we do that, when we pay attention to it, we gradually get to learn what works for what kind of problems and what situation. And we can cycle through this many times. That's kind of the basis of it.
这正是研究告诉我们的，人们通过试错来应对。有时需要四五次尝试。但当我们这样做时，当我们关注它时，我们逐渐了解到什么对什么类型的问题和什么情况有效。我们可以多次循环这个过程。这基本上就是它的基础。
So once a person has figured out what it takes for them to actually be resilient, Is that a stable trait then? In other words, the more that they're confronted with traumatic events, will they always continue to be resilient throughout? I wish that were the case. Unfortunately, it's not because it's really a matter of always putting in the effort and doing it. And it's partly because when we think about potentially traumatic events, we tend to think of them because they're all called potentially traumatic events.
所以一旦一个人弄清楚了自己真正具有韧性需要什么，那这就是一种稳定的特质吗？换句话说，他们越是面对创伤事件，他们就会在今后一直保持韧性吗？我希望是这样。不幸的是，并非如此，因为这实际上取决于始终付出努力并去做到这一点。部分原因是因为当我们想到潜在创伤事件时，我们倾向于这么想，因为它们都被称为潜在创伤事件。
The same thing if we decide to call them traumas. We tend to think of if something is a trauma, that all traumas are the same. But the simple fact is that all the challenges we face in life are dramatically differently, present us with very different challenges. So coping with a natural disaster is going to be challenging in different ways than coping with, say, an abuse situation. But even within one of those subcategories, natural disasters, they're going to present us with all kinds of different challenges.
如果我们决定把它们叫做创伤，也是一样的。我们往往认为，如果某事是创伤，那么所有的创伤都是一样的。但一个简单的现实是，我们在生活中面临的所有挑战都是截然不同的，给我们带来的挑战也大不相同。因此，应对自然灾害与应对虐待情况的挑战将以不同的方式充满挑战。甚至在这些子类别之一的自然灾害中，它们也会给我们带来各种不同的挑战。
So coping with a hurricane is different than. coping with an earthquake, which is different than coping with a flood, which is different than a volcano, yeah. And I've been in a couple of, I've almost drowned a couple times in floods, and I think it's happened to me now three times in my life. And this is mostly my own stupidity that ended up in these situations. But each one of those events was dramatically different in itself. So the challenges that life can throw at us are never really going to be quite the same. You know, we can generalize some, but we're always going to have to kind of think it through. What do I need to do here? What is going on now? And what do I have in my,
因此，应对飓风与应对地震不同，应对地震与应对洪水不同，应对洪水与火山爆发也不同，是的。我经历过几次，我有几次差点在洪水中淹死，我想这在我一生中已经发生过三次了。这主要是因为我自己的愚蠢才陷入了这些情况。但每一个事件本身都是截然不同的。因此，生活抛给我们的挑战永远不会完全相同。你知道，我们可以做一些概括，但我们总是不得不仔细思考。我在这里需要做什麽？现在正在发生什么？我手头有什么
at my disposal that can address this particular piece? In addition to that, there's also a motivational component, which I hadn't mentioned that. We call that the flexibility mindset. And that's a mindset for engaging with the event. It's a mindset. It says, all right, I didn't want this to happen, but I'll get through it. I usually do. The world usually goes on eventually. We could put this really, we could broaden this out right now to, there's a lot of people feel right now that the world is going insane. And if anyone's feeling that way, the flexibility mindset would be, well, it will get through this event. And then something else will happen and we'll get through that. So that mindset is motivating. And I think that if we don't have that,
可以解决这个特定问题的资源？除此之外，还有一个动机组件，我刚才没提到。我们称之为“灵活性心态”。这是一种与事件互动的精神状态。这是一种心态。它说：好吧，我不想让这发生，但我会挺过去的。我通常都能挺过去。世界通常最终会继续运转。我们可以把这个扩展开来，目前有很多人觉得世界正在变得疯狂。如果有人有这种感觉，灵活性心态就是：嗯，我们会挺过这个事件的。然后还会发生别的什么事，我们会挺过那件事的。所以这种心态是有激励作用的。我认为如果我们没有那种
kind of motivation. We're not going to do the work we have to do. And unfortunately, it is work. So there's a long answer to your question is that we can have these tools and these tools really help and we can hone them and develop them. And it gives us more to work with when something happens, but we still have to do it each time. A lot of people who listen to this podcast are parents. Can parents do anything to help teach their kids to be more resilient through life? I'm reluctant to say anything that parents should do because I don't want to, I want to give parents all the benefit of doubt I can. But I think flexibility is obviously part of whatever I would say is an answer, given what I've said so far. And it's part of what we see the developmental
动力。我们将无法做我们必须做的工作。不幸的是，这确实是工作。所以对你问题的长篇回答是，我们可以拥有这些工具，这些工具确实很有帮助，我们可以磨练和发展它们。当事情发生时，它为我们提供了更多可以运用的东西，但我们仍然必须每次都亲自动手去做。很多收听这个播客的人都是父母。父母能做些什么来帮助教育他们的孩子在生活中更有韧性吗？我不愿对父母应该做什么指手画脚，因为我不想，我想给父母所有我能给予的信任。但我认为，鉴于我到目前为止所说的话，灵活性显然是我给出的答案的一部分。这也是我们看到发展
researchers have documented this for years, this gradual development of these kind of skills in kids into adulthood. And there was a few wonderful review articles. not long ago describing what the end point of development was. And it was essentially this kind of flexibility that I'm describing. It takes a while to learn all this. There's a learning process. There's also the development of our brains that give us the tools we need. And I think we can help our kids to be more resilient, to be healthier people,
研究人员多年来记录的一部分，即儿童向成年期过渡时这些技能的逐渐发展。不久前有一些精彩的综述文章，描述了发展的终点是什么。它本质上就是我所描述的这种灵活性。学会这一切需要时间。这是一个学习过程。这也是我们大脑发育的过程，它赋予了我们所需的工具。我认为我们可以通过鼓励孩子们去尝试事物、鼓励他们包容错误，来帮助我们的孩子们变得更有韧性、更健康，
by encouraging them to try things, by encouraging them to tolerate mistakes. and you know, because trial and error learning is very important. And if we don't try things, we can't learn anything new. And if we're, you know, we have to be able to make mistakes, live with mistakes. It's how we grow and develop. And I think that's a crucial thing right now to be able to allow children to make mistakes. But we don't teach them by traumatizing them. Well, we don't want to traumatize them, no.
你知道的，因为试错学习非常重要。如果我们不去尝试，我们就学不到任何新东西。如果我们，你知道的，我们必须能够犯错，与错误共存。这就是我们成长和发展的方式。我认为现在至关重要的一点是，要能够允许孩子们犯错。但我们不能通过创伤化他们来教育他们。嗯，我们不想创伤化他们，不。
But, you know, again, to go back to the idea of a potential trauma, difficult experience is not a trauma until we don't get over it, right? So I think that's a nice way to think about it. So what are you working on now? What are the big questions that you're still trying to answer? We're doing a lot of work on the flexibility idea and we're trying to find different ways to be able to assess it. We're trying to find ways that we can really get at it in a simpler way so we can talk with people about it. I'm also doing a lot of work right now with veterans. I developed a, a, uh, a, uh, a, uh, a, uh, a kind of an approach to veterans a number of years ago where we were seeing that most veterans don't have PTSD, but a lot of veterans, sometimes the majority between 40 and 60 percent,
但是，你知道，再次回到潜在创伤的概念上，艰难的经历在没有过去之前还算不上是创伤，对吧？所以我觉得这是思考这个问题的一个好方法。那么你现在在做什么？你仍在试图解答的重大问题是什么？我们在灵活性这个概念上做了很多工作，并试图找到不同的方法来评估它。我们正试图找到能够以更简单的方式真正切入其中的方法，以便我们能与人们讨论它。我目前也在和退伍军人一起做很多工作。我在多年前针对退伍军人开发了一种方法，当时我们发现大多数退伍军人并没有患上创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），但许多退伍军人——有时甚至占多数，在40%到60%之间——
still struggle when they leave the military. And we decided or coined of the phrase transition stress, that this is a matter of transition stress. And as particularly, any time we go through major transitions, we can experience the stress of transition because we have to adapt to it. We have to kind of rethink many things and re-sort of calibrate our brains in a sense is kind of a new reality. But it's particularly difficult for soldiers. And there are probably other categories that maybe refugees would also experience something similar.
在离开军队后仍然在苦苦挣扎。我们决定使用或创造了“转型压力”这个词，认为这是一个转型压力的问题。尤其是，当我们经历任何重大转型时，我们都会经历转型的压力，因为我们必须去适应它。我们必须在某种程度上重新思考许多事情，并重新校准我们的大脑以适应某种新的现实。但这对于军人来说尤其困难。可能还有其他群体，比如难民，也会经历类似的状况。
But soldiers often go into the military as very, very young people. And they often experience their first true adult identity as soldiers. And the military is a very different world than the non-military world than the civilian world. It's more regimented. It's more highly structured. It has built-in meaning and a clear sense of value and purpose. And that world, in a sense, does a lot of regulating for people, but it also is a very clear and predictable world in many ways. When people leave that world, they kind of often start over. They go to a world where their skills may not transfer. will civilians may not have much of a clue what they went through?
但军人往往在非常非常年轻的时候就参军了。他们通常将作为士兵的经历作为他们真正走向成年后的第一重身份。军队是一个与非军事世界、与平民世界截然不同的世界。它更有纪律性，高度结构化，具有内在的意义以及清晰的价值感和目标感。在某种意义上，那个世界为人们做了大量的调节工作，但在很多方面，它也是一个非常清晰且可预测的世界。当人们离开那个世界时，他们往往需要重新开始。他们进入了一个他们的技能可能无法转化的世界，而平民可能对他们所经历的一切一无所知？
And they have to adapt to a new civilian world. And that's difficult. And many, many veterans accomplish this, of course and go on to live healthy lives. But I'm very interested in that right now. And maybe we can make that a little bit better for veterans. And that's where the flexibility comes in again. We're beginning to work with veterans and flexibility. And we're testing now a training with veterans to see if we can.
而且他们必须适应一个新的平民世界。这很困难。当然，许多许多退伍军人做到了这一点，并继续过着健康的生活。但我现在对这个非常感兴趣。也许我们可以为退伍军人把这个过程做得更好一点。这就是灵活性再次发挥作用的地方。我们开始与退伍军人和灵活性一起工作。我们现在正在对退伍军人进行一项培训测试，看看我们是否能够……
can make that process easier for them. Well, Dr. Bonano, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. I've enjoyed talking to you. Thank you, Kim. It's very nice to talk with you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
让他们的这个过程变得更容易。好的，博南诺博士，我想感谢你今天能来。这真的非常有趣。我很享受与你的交谈。谢谢你，金。和你交谈非常愉快。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学之声》以前的节目。也可以在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's,
如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发送电子邮件：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学之声》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。在拉尔夫超市享受更多省钱方式，
like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time.
比如每个过道都有的低价。当您下载拉尔夫超市应用时，您可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多费用。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油时每加仑最高可省 1 美元。在拉尔夫超市，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。
you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. C-Sight for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您购物。因此，通过节省和奖励，每天都可以轻松省大钱。南加州拉尔夫超市已有 150 多年历史。各州节省金额可能有所不同。燃油限制适用。详情见网站。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。